I'm going to go to the beach in Cannes!
But the train to Cannes left from a different station.
He didn't want to go the wrong way and so he used a compass.
He was at the station!
He asked a man to film him as he got on the train.
Mr. Bean watched as the train left the station with all of his bags on it.
Mr. Bean sat opposite the Russian boy and smiled.
The boy, Stepan, gave him a long, cold look.
He was alone in France because of this stupid man.
Some musicians were in the street.
Mr. Bean started to dance.
They started to give him money.
He was in a beautiful little French town.
There was a big explosion.
Then, some German soldiers followed the tank and ran into the town.
But what about Mr. Bean?
He only cared about one thing.
The beach!